hey everybody welcome to Griffin with
Griffin no Woo's today today is a
special intro today and I thought just
because of everything that's going on in
the world right now with the coronavirus
with the racial upheaval the injustice
that's being brought to light I thought
I would just do my own intro give you my
own thoughts about this on my platform
before I play this episode I I have the
grade I shot alpha on the show she
hasn't she hadn't came out with her own
comedy album and a special that's coming
out on all things comedy and we actually
have a very interesting discussion
before all of this stuff happened with
the protests over George Floyd and we
have a great discussion about me being
mixed in America mixed race and light
skin and just we have our own discussion
and I thought it was a it's interesting
even before all this happened that you
know people of color have been talking
about certain things for a long time and
now this things are being brought to
light so yes I thought woo-woos weren't
appropriate for right now with the black
lives matter movement and what it really
stands for and we should be you know
conscious of that I mean for me like I
say I'm a mixed-race person and I deal
with things in my own way from my own
experience and it's hard right now being
someone that's like sort of in the
public eye I mean I'm not saying I'm
famous or anything but you know just
first of all the pushback you get right
now on the internet that you can't even
post anything without somebody trying to
tell you how you should feel this is
like grieving it's like when someone
dies and we all grieve in our own way
and sometimes people get on you like
what you don't care because you're not
grieving the way they grieve it's the
same thing with protesting my anger
level and what I'm angry about what how
I want to put my energy forward in this
may not be the same as you so don't
assume that you think you care more than
me or that I don't care at all you don't
know me like that and that's all this
happening on
the internet right now is like sometimes
the message is getting lost with
people's charged feelings so we have to
have some empathy for everyone's
sensitivity so it's crazy that we got to
be sensitive to people's sensitivity we
have to know how sensitive people are we
have to be sensitive to that I mean it's
that's what's happening right now like I
went on a walk the other day went on a
walk and then I took a picture of like
this these trees I was like oh this is a
beautiful picture there's some idiot
sends me a message oh nice nice
protesting with the middle finger emoji
and I'm like what it's craziness another
idiot sends me a message why are you
silent on I've got the guys name listed
that's ironic maybe that's the reason
why he was upset at me but he was saying
like what would let me look at it why
are you silent on David Doran I want to
get the guy's name like David Doran he
was the retired black officer I think he
was in his 60s or 70s and he was not
killed by rioters you know why am i
silent on it like it's not I had to tell
this guy's not my place to openly
discuss every single thing on your
timeline I don't have to talk about
every single injustice that's going on
in the world or it or and don't assume
that I don't care about things because
I'm not doing it the way you want who
are you like you have to really ask
yourselves that this demand people have
of people of even the smallest influence
you think that those people are
responsible for the world's happiness
you know hey we have to do our part they
first find out is really what I'm trying
to say find out if I'm doing something
or not before you just judge so you know
cuz that's not helping the cause I think
people are challenged channeling their
negativity their challening channeling
their aggression and and their pent-up
feelings and then they're putting it out
in the wrong place to people that don't
deserve that sort of attitude
my feeling is this is about the term no
justice no peace what does that mean to
you cuz it's important because that's
what I think this is about like I take
I'm gonna let look past the racial part
of it for a second because to me another
main part about what's happened with the
George Floyd incident is the idea of the
abuse of power that old statement power
corrupts is so true that's why there
needs to be oversight the fact that that
cop and those other cops with clearly
watching people film the guys looking at
people film him while he murders this
guy to me says he really thought he was
gonna get away with it and we have to
ask ourselves without filming without
people filming he probably would have
gotten away with it they could have said
anything they wanted it could have said
well he was resisting arrest and how
would we know
so that abuse of power is the problem
it's it so it's one of the main problems
the fact that they thought that they
could get away with this and whatever
they've done in the past well even if it
was as something not as egregious as
murder but it's any kind of abuse of
power once it happens two three four or
five times look you get you get to the
point where like I could kill this guy
and I'll probably I'll probably get off
good even going back to the the terrible
thing with the two white guys you know
shot shot the guy jogging in their
neighborhood I mean there's a certain
attitude that like this sort of thing
can happen and those guys weren't
necessarily cops but turns out they had
connections to the I don't know if it
was the police or some government office
I the district attorney's or whatever
whatever
affiliation they had it was close enough
for them to think I could get away with
this and nasara we have to stop I mean
for me a big problem in the United
States right now is that the media is
supposed to be the fourth branch of
government you know the news the news is
supposed to be where
we get our information and it keeps the
government in check something goes up
then the news goes hey this is what's
happening here's an expose here's here's
an interview with someone but now we're
in a situation where we can't trust the
news at all you know you have to take it
all with a grain of salt I just don't
like that so now we have a fifth branch
of government and you know what that is
it's you every individual that holds up
their cell phone when there's an arrest
to going on thank God that happened
that's what we have to do we have to
keep recording keep filming keep putting
that stuff out until there's a change
there needs to be some oversight so we
have to start the oversight with our
devices you just film put it out
document document that stuff to be like
hey look this is what happens so then
maybe there'll be some real change
because the change has to come in the
chain of command it has to come with you
know oversight so once that gets into
place then maybe maybe these kinds of
things won't happen because you can't
legislate how people feel I mean if
people have prejudice and people have
preferences and and that turns into
racist behavior how can you please that
well we have to at least make sure if
you're a racist and you want to be a cop
okay but you just can't be racist at
work you know what I mean and that's a
hard thing to try to
legislate is to look after like to make
sure that that's car is hard so we have
to do that with education we have to do
that with love we have to spread love
and we have to you know make sure that
the good cops know they thank you for
what you do it's tough situation but I
need you to know I'm with you
this has been difficult times I mean the
coronavirus is going on I mean I
personally got I got some attacked
another time on the internet because I
was saying like I'm not for looting I
understand why looting happens I
understand with pent-up energy and years
and years of systemic racism and and
disenfranchise people feel like they
have nothing then you you you add that
to this coronavirus pandemic and the
quarantine that with 40 million people
out of work and people in home at home
been pent up and then this is just an
explosion okay so I get it but I don't
agree with looting and my thing was why
are you out looting during a pandemic
you people got get masks on you know
people don't even have masks on
I saw I saw this kid white kid walking
out us he's on camera looks right at the
camera whoever was filming looks right
at him
with a surfboard his long white hair and
he's just walking out like I got this
you know I'm like they're gonna get you
people don't remember in 92 after the
Rodney King riots they got footage
there's there's surveillance footage and
whoever they can get they got so you're
out there thinking you're gonna get away
with you got your Louis Vuitton bag or
you got your whatever you stole you're
on camera some of you are gonna get
arrested you got its you're gonna go
down and hey
maybe you sacrifice yourself for the
cause because maybe all of this will
lead towards some real change in the
looting and fires contributed to pushing
forward the change but there's
consequences to your actions but anyways
I'm just putting out there like why
would you want to be out looting during
a pandemic because if you get arrested
you have more chances to get sick you
think these cops care about people's
safety at that point you know they're
out there like okay arrest them all put
them all on the thing take the masks off
because we have to take pictures of them
that you and a paddy wagon you added the
thing you if they letting you out in
three hours
you're still in confined spaces with a
bunch of people you don't know who's
sick or not I'm 48 years old I'm not
trying to be out here get sick you know
that I known people that have gotten
really sick from this I want to see my
mom again I want to give my mom a hug I
don't want to have be sick and then get
my mom sick and she dies because of me I
mean the the coronavirus is something
that yes cuz all these young people who
are like good few years you get to be 85
you you know okay well don't you want to
hug your grandma don't you want to be
near your peers so that's where I was
coming from but of course you know you
get [ __ ] for that it's like you don't
understand you need to have this you
know unrest because that's what chain
how change happens it's like you know
people don't hear what you're saying all
I'm saying is be safe if you have to
lose put a mask on you don't get you
know I don't agree with it I don't
condone it I like to peaceful protest
but sometimes peaceful don't work you
know how can you be peaceful with no
justice which takes it back to what I
was saying so if we don't feel it
there's being justice done on one side
why should justice be done on the other
side you know sometimes you got to fight
for justice and that's the unfortunate
byproduct of that but anyways be safe
out there
try to get into a dialogue with people
that are different than you you know
that's important to talk it's not - like
like even if you're listen if you're out
there you're white you're tired of
hearing about black
lives matter you want to use people just
like I'm not a racist you know my father
wasn't a racist yeah okay it hasn't
touched you and affected you in a
certain way but that doesn't mean you
have to like take the opposite side it
doesn't mean you have to like you know
go at people like well why aren't you
saying something about these looters are
doing this how about we talk about why
these things are happening let's talk
about why people are all bent up let's
talk about why you feel the way you feel
they you feel wrong do you feel that
you're being lumped in with people that
have nothing to do with you if we have a
conversation and dialogue if you have an
intelligent back and forth let's talk
about logic let's let's let's let's try
to figure out why we're so emotional and
sensitive and like work together towards
a common goal then maybe we can actually
solve this problem but if you think
you're helping by putting out your
negativity by putting out your
narrow-minded view of the world and
thinking everybody should think like you
hey it's not helping but on a more
positive note like I said I have the
very talented miss I should alpha on the
show she's got a great album amount and
her specials coming out in July and you
know I recorded this episode with her
before all this unrest but as I looked
back at the episode we really had a very
interesting discussion about race and
how we each other how we both look and
how it affected our upbringing and I
think this is the kind of conversations
that are important so I hope you enjoy
the episode be safe out there you know
wear your masks keep your social
distancing going and if you're out there
protesting with peaceful protest keep
doing - keep doing your work keep
spreading the message let's like you
know let's change the system let's get
some accountability and remember not all
cops are bad - they're not all bad
there's some bad apples and you know and
the good ones they need to be more vocal
about the bad ones because we can't have
any bad ones in that position
so that's how we're gonna work together
to solve this problem but for now please
enjoy this episode of riffing with
Griffin and as always thank you for
watching
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
program we've never met which is how we
met yeah
I came and did the right
I shall feh yes that's right you were
running your because you were gonna do
what was it for yeah I need the album in
November with a TC and then they we also
videoed it so the video is gonna come
out on their website
okay that's kudos yeah album just came
out on Friday but you say it like a
video like it's not like necessarily a
special well I mean I guess they always
laugh at me they're like why are you
saying that it's a special I was like I
know by things because we originally
know I'm like dumpling but but we
originally were just doing the album and
I was like I just wanna get some video
so we can get some clips right like that
was the whole like thing for me but then
the video like turned out really well I
think I like I come across better in
video than any other medium so I think
they're like oh snap okay we gotta like
put this together so now we have like a
proper actual like there's an intro
there's like you know it's a fun so I'm
like a video to like you're full-on
production yeah yeah but it's like it's
weird cuz like what is the difference
these days right cuz you got like say
you know if somebody's doing it themself
as opposed to like is it having somebody
else write a check that's what makes it
like official what makes it official
I'll be like we I guess the humbleness
of being a comic sometimes is like try
to downplay it oh I did a little video
you like about
it's not a video because it like legit
it's got like the marquee and like you
know the intro and the people and
there's like like all the parts and then
he'll like you know produced by all
things comedy except so I write a full
Ennis I think it's just in my mind
because we did the album and I was like
great this is a bonus but then it ended
up being so much better than we thought
but they ended up bringing four cameras
in I think because the more they saw me
perform they're like oh yeah she's got a
point like getting a video would be
great like let's put this together if it
works out great and then it worked out
so they're like cool like do this you
know like a video is like somebody was
holding up a cell phone it was like like
a selfie for your story angles they had
some the actual comes I use my selfies
on the whole time this day did you need
a gimmick so it's like that would have
hit the thing selfie special with the
whole thing everyone's like I got a good
GoPro in the ceiling and you're like
it's bad video it's bad town why are we
doing this you know stupid fisheye thing
why is that a thing I know on a
motorcycle or you were going underwater
or you were some sorta like shark chase
it's like no one wants to see it on a
GoPro camera something like this is
gonna sound way more kinky than I intend
to put like there was something about
just like watching people live their
lives that is so like fascinating to me
and I would just love like if there was
a world where you could just watch
people live their lives without them
knowing and it wasn't a creepy thing I'd
be I did you're all about Truman Show
then you are you voyeuristic is that you
think I'm like weird the brothers it's
just like fascinating like I think
everybody's life is so interesting and
the way people do things is interesting
and you don't have to be like doing
something wrong or bad I just like I'd
love to know like how do you spend a
Sunday you know like it's just the
boring stuff is so interesting to me now
do you think that it's like that here's
a question if is it that people's lives
are interesting or is it interesting
that you're watching people's lives and
they don't know
[Laughter]
let me explain why I ask okay so you got
you know you got pornhub you got like so
many like Internet pornography is like
WWE it's so easy to get whatever you
want whatever your Flash is whatever it
is you can just click it in but like it
seems that like right now something like
only fans where it's basically just
people going you know hey this is me and
you could you know pay me directly to do
what you could get for free is this just
something about that something about
like the realness of stuff you know me
like you movies are great we know we go
to movies we know they're fake we know
you know even if it's a true story it's
a fake version of that true story but
like the realness and I think there's
something about we want to see how other
people do it compared to what I do
whether it's sex whether it's how you
spend your Sunday whether it's like you
know when you're alone and you talk to
yourself or whatever is like am i weird
am i different am i cool like I want to
know based on you doing you without you
knowing I'm watching yeah even if you
only are or if there's something about
someone allowing you into so even if
they know cuz like a lot of these things
are people like you know hey I'm gonna
fill my life I guess that's why remember
do you remember like when the Osborne's
first did their reality that blew up
into this thing that's turned into like
you know multi-billion dollar you know
like when they first came out when they
actually were I'm more of a reality you
know to me because now it's like there's
production there's editing like you can
create whatever story you want but I
feel like back then it was actually just
people living their lives and people
were watching really it's a green I
think it's always been this really is
all but yeah I think there's always been
the masterminds behind television
production knew that you know making
people it's just it's the reason why
documentaries are so popular is because
there's this falseness to them that like
well this is true this is like an
encyclopedia so when you present
something as a documentary no matter
what narrative you have on the
documentary
people are gonna look at it and give it
give it clout because the word
documentaries on it
it's like it's always through someone's
lens right like everybody that you see
that's made by somebody else is gonna be
through sometimes I think though that's
why going back to my creepiness that's
why I want to see when people don't know
because then it's not through a lens
it's just like other than the actual
physical there's a lens watching
somebody like you're not editing what
you're doing if you don't know I'm
watching like that's the that's the true
essence like I want to steal your
essence I want to know what you're doing
when nobody is around you don't I mean
that is creepy but I just like it's I
just find things fat like I'll sometimes
just watch when I'm like you know in a
cafe or something we just can't like
watch somebody live their life and I'm
like this is so fascinating like what
could be happening right now like what
are they doing who are they talking to
why they getting so upset like just that
whole I don't know maybe it's I think
it's like there's a creativity in that
to like watching people and seeing how
it how you interpret what's going on
yeah but isn't that like the nature of
being a comic though too is that like
you know we don't even realize it but
we're subconsciously searching for
material at all times yeah like you know
it's like there's like an there's like
an analyzing that goes on when like
every time you see something happened
and you go oh look at this this is how I
see it right that we need that that
stimulus yeah I think so yeah definitely
and then you put it through your own
lens and that's what you like that's why
people can talk about the same stuff
over and over but each person has that
different take on it or that you know
they go in a slightly different
direction have you always wanted to have
you out have you always wanted to be a
comic like where you from what's his
story
no yeah yeah I have not always wanted to
be a comedian
I started out big athlete that's what I
like did yeah before so I was a no I'm
only 5'4 okay you looked all right yeah
I got this upward lens going on ya know
I played basketball and did track and
field and then played soccer to a high
level and then ended up playing in
university and playing pro and then
going and playing in a men's league in
South Korea
and yeah that was sort of like my life
was I studied sport psychology and
university and everyone I think thought
I was going to continue on doing that
and be like a broadcaster or a coach or
us you know and then like I was I was
like I don't know that this doesn't seem
like I think a lot of my a lot of when I
was growing up it was like I was good at
something so people were just like great
here's opportunities for that thing and
I was like okay you know I never really
chose anything I was kind of like just
going with the flow of things and having
a good time and I was good at sports oh
I played sports and then I ended up
playing to a high level but then at the
end I was like is this really what my
whole life is like am I in this nut
shell of just I'm an athlete and it
didn't feel at all like me I had
injuries I knew I wasn't gonna be able
to play forever I didn't want a coach I
had no interest in coaching so I was
like okay I got a second life out you
know and just kind of quit all that
completely and then when in no regrets
with no no but rational it wasn't even
like I was like you know that hanging on
I was never getting play time I was
still it like not quite my peak but like
you know I was still up there doing well
playing on a team that was doing well
and yeah I just I have no regrets I'm
like I had a great time I would I don't
want a place I have no interest in
playing soccer on a team and like an
organized league whatsoever
I would love to play in like a weekend
terment where you get to drink beer but
like that's it
that's all I want I'm too competitive in
my mind enough in shape enough to be
able to like have those two you didn't
mean be oh let me ask a question then
okay so then was part of the reason why
you didn't continue in it is because
it's like if I'm not in it in it I don't
want to just like I don't want to I
don't want to coach I don't want to be a
broadcaster cuz I was a high level
athlete so if I can't do that I don't
want nothing to do with this yeah I'm
not interested in being on the sidelines
and like being like here's what you to
do anything part of it is to be honest I
was never even I never grew up being
like I want to be an athlete you know so
I wasn't like the mentality of like
strategize and chalk talk and all the
stuff I was just like I know I'm gonna
go out and play and I know that when
this happens I do this I don't know why
I don't know what the system is I just
go when I play and I score lots of goals
like that was just the thing so
to be a coach like I really didn't
actually have the insight and the
ability to explain like I'd be like just
go there because that's where you should
know to go like there's no you know
teacher in that sense of me but yeah
like I don't want to I don't want to
like when I watch the World Cup now I'm
like chomping at the bit and like I want
to be back like there's a part of me
that's like Oh remember when we were
that level and like oh it felt like I'm
just like I want to get back there but
I'm not gonna train four hours a day
well that was gonna be one of you answer
one the question I was gonna ask next is
do you still feel do you have that you
still obviously used to have a
competitive fire I mean so it's not just
for sports then right I mean it's just
carries over it does it carry over into
everything you do yeah I think like I
think definitely I'm very competitive
and my husband will be like uh-huh she's
feel competitive you know to a fault
probably in certain ways but like I like
you racing to the mailbox
I just had a baby a while ago right and
when like this is this is how my
competitive nature comes out like I want
a kid to love me the most
you mean like this is this he wakes up I
like race to get in there faster sigh
hey it's me I'm almost like I'm like I'm
like there's that in me where I I just
want to be you know the best mom
possible and momming is like there's
never you can never be good at it like
it's just you're always failing so I
think that's the part where it's like
bad you know right right after Mother's
Day yesterday I'm like a mother more
interesting things about you one you're
married you got your first kid yeah yeah
first all the congratulations and happy
Mother's Day this might come out like
weeks after Mother's Day this is current
for us so I had Mother's Day to you well
then yeah so you're really pursuing a
difficult field right now then with all
this marriage a kid and then still
trying to get into this mostly
male-dominated profession you know how
is that all that going for me and the
reason why I asked is because of
something that you said about
being the 1 female on a Korean men's
team I would over employed yes it was a
men's league in Korea mostly expats from
the UK and from America and Canada who
had played professionally before
whatever at a high level they were in
this league and I went over one of my
friends a guy I knew from university
played in the league and he was like you
know I was in this job and I wasn't
didn't know what I wanted to do and he's
like you should come over you can plan
our team we'll get you into the tryouts
and then you know you can work teaching
to make some money on the side and stuff
like that and I went and he was like he
just told him he's like yeah my buddy's
gonna come from Canada and try out for
the team and so I show up and they're
like oh that's cute his little
girlfriend's gonna put on her cleats
like kick a ball on the side and I went
on the pitch and it was like a scrimmage
- for the first tryout and I scored
three goals and they were like oh ok you
ok [ __ ] like we can't we can't ignore
this we can't just pretend she's not
good and not have her on the team so I
ended up like getting on the team and it
was a shock for every other team because
there was there's never been a female
player and there's no rules it's
strictly like a strict rule against
having a female just called a men's
league you know so there wasn't it
didn't say women couldn't play but every
time I went they would always be like
you have a woman and they'd be all up in
their face and I'm like oh you're gonna
let a little girl and a team scare you
and they're like oh yeah you're right
let's do this you know and then I would
I would be like a vicious like full-on
I'm like yeah let's go like I I really
am very very competitive especially if
there's anything about like gender stuff
it gets like the hair on the back of my
neck up I'm like okay now it's home you
know category do you categorize yourself
as a feminist then yeah I guess I mean
like I think it's kind of a dirty word I
grew up just with like not being a
feminist I just grew up with both of you
kids are the same [ __ ] you know so it
wasn't like like my brother and I
weren't treated super differently there
were a few things that were different
you know any mean but like I wasn't I
didn't grow up thinking like I've gotta
be in dresses and I should be trying to
find a man and I should be getting
married and all this kind of stuff
um even though ironic
you did all that no I mean it took a
long time my mom at my wedding and she
made this feature she was like you know
we had just resolved that it was never
gonna happen we were never gonna have
kids from her she was never like okay
great like yeah I'm old and now I'm
finally doing it we gotta put you in
spinster statuses so no one has said the
thing is we got married and like on our
honeymoon we got pregnant so I was like
I was like from single lady to married
with a kid with in like a year it was
just like full-on transformation which
was you know a lot I feel like that's
part of your competitive thing too like
you're like your whole family was like
no I'm not a spring chicken and we were
like yeah we'll start trying it takes
people like years and then like before
we could finish that sentence we're like
oh [ __ ] like we got a baby now you know
back to like this you saw I see a
competitive nature
yeah gender issues like a trigger you
and so like you know so how does that
house a comedy that affected you in the
last like three or four years especially
on the heels of you know the me to
movement and yeah and then the changes
and all the changes that are there are
there changes you know changes I mean
like this is the thing it's um it's the
same [ __ ] that happens everywhere you
know I mean it's not like this is unique
to comedy or entertainment or you know
this is like the thing that's happening
to women and men and people who are
different like transgendered people like
it's just the same stuff that's
happening everywhere like white men have
ruled for a very long time this is we're
all just trying to climb in like you
know figure that make it equal that's
why I'm like I don't know if I would
call myself like I'm a strict feminist
or something I'm just like I think well
people should just be treated the same
like old young black white what like
just everyone's a person if you're an
[ __ ] you're an [ __ ] you know I
mean like let's just all be the same
I'm the word like it's like an
equalities you coolest coolest equalist
I understand I understand what you're
saying and I don't bring that up to make
you uncomfortable about it or anything
like that I mean I could tell I could
tell you I could tell by your reaction
that it's just one of those questions
it's like and that's part of the problem
I guess it's like here we go I'm a woman
what's it like being a black woman in
comedy and I was like I've never been a
white man in comedy I don't know what to
tell you like what how the difference is
I just know my experience maybe there's
stuff because I'm a woman maybe there's
stuff because I'm black but like I mean
honestly I'm in my whole life I've been
doing a lot of stuff that's been in a
male-dominated field so for me it
doesn't feel that shocking to have
people sometimes say like oh women
aren't funny or you know I I'm not
people are really saying that anymore
but like what's really more bothersome
to me sometimes is when all this stuff
happens
people go oh we want to interview you
because you're a woman and I'm like can
you interview me because I'm funny or
because what you like what I'm doing or
you know you mean all those other things
that are the reason why I'm doing this
and like I have something to say like
what about that stuff and so a lot of
times when there's just people like we
wanted you because you're black we want
interview because this happened and it's
women and we want it like I'm like it's
still like a quota essentially like I'm
that token thing so it'll be interesting
when someone's when there's more people
just interviewing me because they like
my album or they you know thought this
bit was funny or whatever it is you know
yeah I hear what you're saying I mean
it's just like it's a difficult listen
I'm I'm in this I'm in the same I'm in a
different boat but like we're on the
same seed you know just being like you
know being a minority in in any business
it's like it's like a weird you know and
every time we think like things are
different then there's something in the
news that makes you go it's always these
ways that we're like okay things oh no
okay it's all the same it's the same
[ __ ] that's going on all the time but
yeah I mean I don't know it's kind of
tiring in a way which sounds bad joining
me in like where this is the thing
they're always hope is that you mean you
know but at the same time it does exist
so I'm
like deny that that exists or anything
but you know you know what I'm listening
just so you know I'm totally on the same
page with you on this I can just tell
about your facial expressions and stuff
like that - I totally get you saying
it's like let me tell you where I'm at
right now like like when I look like
this i'ma watch a movie right if I if
the movie is like some kind of period
piece and it's pre-1970 and I'm like I
don't know if I want to watch it because
one there better be racism in it at some
point I get to a point where I'm like
this again yeah it's like it's like but
at the same time I go I understand the
message is important I'm not trying to
be like oh I don't think this is
important but it a certain point you
just go really another you know a white
guilt movie because like the period
pieces like it's because I'm an actor as
well right just leave you're an actor's
like well I feel like we're all actors
as well but um this idea that you know
there's so many roles there like well
it's a period piece there's not really a
lot of roles for people who aren't white
and I'm like you know we existed though
right like we were still around who's
making the period pieces that happen at
that time from the other people's
perspective like that would be I mean I
want to see more of that stuff but
anyway I just I I feel you but at the
same time it's like you go what with it
like okay yeah you like what were there
what was the upper middle-class upwardly
mobile
what were the rich black people doing in
1960 you know it's like where are those
stories where the rich people doing a
lot I'm saying like what I'm saying is
like yay I agree with you it's like you
know period piece it's like okay so the
important things in periods seem to be
only white right yeah things that are
black or any minority it's always
overcoming some [ __ ] white people did
write like those are the stories so it's
like we're saying we're the stories of
just by people living in a neighborhood
right right and just that contain
neighborhood and like you know my I was
the love story or the like you know like
I think that part of it too is even how
we describe her I like the stuff the
stories then the black story but the
other the white side of it is the
period story like their their history
and where the the asterisks of history
you know black version but the fact that
we even like I hate it
I even think of it like this I know like
when I watch something I just go oh
you're making me think about this that's
why I like science fiction I want to get
lost in like something else right even
then that stuff you go you're like there
was you know you might be like where
there was no black kids and this made-up
universe like I just want to get to a
point where I don't even think about
that I now want that to be a thing
that's my coolest you know I mean I
don't want to think about the stuff I
just want to like see what I'm seeing
out there reflected in art and in all
these which is I mean it sounds very
artsy fartsy kind of like what my art
towards like the real life it's like me
but by the way but by the way I'm not I
don't subscribe to that all the time
either I mean yeah I'm going to
Hollywood to escape you mean so yeah if
I'm watching CSI something-or-other yeah
I want my CSI agent to be hot you know
why if I want to see ugly people I could
just go to the post office or wherever
else I mean I'm trying to escape I'm
trying to be room for the shows for the
people who aren't the good look at me
like I grew up in Canada and like this
show the show is the most famous for me
was Degrassi now depressing now love
Degrassi all good-looking people but
when it started I'm telling you that
back if you go back I don't know you
even know if you can find them but if
you can go back and find us first de
grassi's they got zits they got bad hair
they're chunky like it's like it's real
life people which I'm like only reason
Esther it stood out because you had all
the other things so that was like
Canadian we were it was like the only
thing Canada could afford what I don't
know pull these kids off the street put
our leg you know camcorder you know you
know it's funny but Degrassi is like it
was also like they were a true to age so
that yeah like you would see high school
kids would be like these guys are young
the United States
I mean 28 you're a senior in high school
on the show right
I was on Degrassi as a teacher and like
at the time then - I was like old enough
to be a teacher but because when they
like dressed me hip they're like ah man
you look too young so I started dressing
me more like marm ish they had like
turtlenecks and these long skirts
because they're like we're playing to
age but you're you know the black don't
crack ruin this story I grew up together
you know I was born in Nigeria I'm half
Nigerian but I grew up in Canada
oh so you related to Obama no kidding
that's how people from Africa you mix me
get Obama money yeah you know I was a
kid in the 80s so you know it's like
bein light-skinned was like back in the
80s it was like a big deal like that was
like some kind of we get to
light-skinned hate oh that sort of went
away I think it went away like mid-90s
and then it just
we got lumped in with everybody else
where was like you know that you became
like sort of just like you were part of
the black culture yeah I was I was never
I always grew up being like when I go to
Nigeria they literally thought I was
white and they would yell like hey my
kid in the street obviously in you know
how sorry Earth or whatever but and then
I would come home to Canada and like I
was like the black friend so I really
was like what the [ __ ] like this is - I
don't know what's going on and then my
dad was working in South Africa and I
was going to South Africa and have you
if you've ever if you've never been
being a mixed-race person you're gonna
go and be like look at all these people
who look exactly like me like having
grown up there would have been such a
joy in certain ways I mean obviously not
at that time but like you know but like
to see people who looked like me cuz in
Canada where I grew up there was like
there weren't a lot of black people
there weren't a lot of mixed there was
less linked mixed people so I wasn't
seeing anybody that I could be like you
know we have a similar oh no no we don't
like when I went to South Africa I was
literally like there they call them
coloured like that's the non offensive
term for like these people who are mixed
black and white and I was like I am
coloured I have found
this is the thing but see that's a weird
that you say that cuz it's a weird
feeling that we still feel like that is
that it means is that something innate
in us to be like wanna be around people
that look like us
evolutionary you know like you you see
people who are the same as you and you
go okay like you know you understand
there's just unspoken like the black man
nod you know like the black lady kind of
like how do you do and like there's just
something that you connect on whether
you connect in real life or not but you
have that you give it this thing which
is even weird because like my mom is
like the whitest white lady who's ever
lived so you don't I mean and I have a
lot in common with her but like if I saw
her on the road I'm like people stopping
me in my mom on the street like meeting
up they would be like how did these two
people meet like it just doesn't make
any sense if you look at my mom yeah so
many times people at shows are something
big I think your mom's here and they
point out some black lady in the front
row and I was like oh no no no no no you
gonna see my mom she's gonna glow the
place up when she walks in don't worry I
liked a lot of times people from Canada
they don't understand the American this
racial divide between black and white
but it's not because there's no racism
in Canada not because there's no racism
in Canada and yeah ain't true because
they can't stand Aborigines or whoever
those trains and all shutting down the
trains it's actually what's going on
there right now is equivalent and
sometimes worse than what's happening in
the United States yeah it's like a
different story cuz here black people
were brought over against their will and
then you don't even made slaves
knowledge that theater white people came
into this land and we're like yeah now
this is ours and they were like so then
you know still today like a couple years
ago was Canada's 150th you know
anniversary birthday whatever and Justin
Trudeau and the whole of the government
had still never apologized to the
indigenous people of Canada for stealing
the country and like you know II mean
and so he had this opportunity and
instead he threw a party called party at
the fort which is historically where all
of the you know fur traders and and
people who came over Europeans they
would make a fort around themselves
keep themselves away from the indigenous
people and like that was his celebration
of Canada they were just like you've got
to be kidding me right now like the
insensitivity of it all you know so yeah
there's definitely there's definitely
racism in Canada but like people when I
moved here expected me to really in my
bones understand experientially
understand the the plight and the racism
and the culture of it and it was almost
like I felt like I was appropriating a
culture because people would put that on
me like oh you get it you know you come
on sister and I was like like I
understand through reading and watching
and talking to people but like I don't
not that I don't want to be on the side
I'm like I want to be on the side I just
don't want to pretend like this is what
I grew up with because it's just not you
know you know what I know exactly what
you're saying it's very interesting
because I have a lot my family's from
like Belize okay so I offend me from
Belize Central America Jamaica Honduras
I have this is where my family but like
Belize for instance was a slave port but
they got their independence in the 70s
so the experience of like Caribbean
Americans so when Caribbeans come to the
United States they don't have the same
experience right and understanding that
people that grew up in the United States
who are black so there's like a divide
there yeah you know you know they're
like well we got our independence we
have a country we have a great you know
an American black people like what are
you talking about we you know even
though even though around the same time
you know more culture has been grown
from the black experience you know like
jazz and soul food and all these things
that they there is a culture but it just
it just grew in a place of you know
wickedness you know I mean you know came
flora you know you know came from after
post slavery stuff but a culture was
formed but these when people when black
people come from different places
I understand they just don't have the
same experience I didn't go up I didn't
go up having this hate of white people
either right I was thought it was
strange I'll never forgive me and I used
to go to the Beverly Hills YMCA my mom
I'm taking to the Bellevue's YMCA you
know and I remember this the first time
I ever experienced racism was this kid
just white kid you know you know he just
like he said oh I don't want to go on
the pool with you because your skin is
dirty
and I remember it's hurtful but I wasn't
mad per se I really was like oh it's
happening my first experience this is
interesting and my brain has always been
like that where I just wanted to be like
yo why you why do you feel this way like
I was just like I always have thought
like thought about it that way it's so
like so then as I later in life and like
racism like goes as it's not as
prevalent as it was you know you go from
it but it's crazy though because you I'm
going all over the place but it's
interesting to me like to watch like
when that oj documentary came out did
you ever watch that ESPN oj document no
I watched look like a like a snippet but
not oh what was interesting about it is
in the beginning of it they were going
back to like this 50 60 70 s and what
was going on with the police back then
so you hear those things you go damn why
is that stuff still happening it's such
a big scale but you know that stuff
still happening then you have like the
Rodney King and you have all these
things that happen and then like now you
have this like guy you know I've got the
abri whatever the guys name is who's
like hunted down by these two my man
yeah yeah they've been out of jail for
like 70 days and now there's like some
kind of conspiracy about it you just go
do that kind of stuff still happens but
you know no it just reminds you like
today I was like I you know my albums
out and posting these videos and stuff
and I have a 800-pound gorilla Records
made this great like animated video of
part of one of my jokes and it starts
off black people make the world better
and it's a whole joke about how like you
know you can't the good things that a
lot of the good things that are here is
because black people did it then some
was like oh let's take that and let's
roll with it you know II mean and it you
know in the end it's kind of this joke
about appropriation essentially and I
posted that and I'm loving it mm-hmm and
just before I you called I saw on my
Facebook page some guy on who he is but
some guy posted and he was like yeah
that's why you make great slaves and
then he put all these like happy
laughing emoji faces and then he wrote
back again and he was like something but
like yeah yeah [ __ ] you you stupid ass
[ __ ] and I was like look at me it was
like kind of like funny cuz I'm like
this is just like bad or
like you don't even like this isn't even
this is like nothing this is not
affecting me in a way that makes me feel
about it's just like so like I don't
even want to call it low-hanging fruit
it's like below that you know I mean
it's the rotting fruit that's on the
ground and you're like come on give me
something better like make fun of my
shape my face my hair like something
give me something I got my eyes it's
like I think they were from a generation
right now that like that it's kind of
stuff isn't as hurtful yeah because it's
just like really yeah you know me like a
slight just go you yeah groovy I go do
better tell me my beer like stupider you
know but it's personal but it's like if
you put that to some people you know
what I think it is I think there's a
generation of white people who are mad
that they never got their opportunity to
be racist yeah never got it it's like oh
man this is passed em by so now like
even when they're not being waste it's
like I had this joke about had this joke
about like like younger millennial and
maybe in their 30s why people right now
racism to them is like being in an
elevator where somebody already farted
elevator and you're like I farted in
here and there's some white people come
in and you go no some black people come
in and the white people go I didn't do
that there's like the unsegmented people
and like especially the ignorant ones
who were just like oh I remember when
this used to be okay
I remember I would hurt people you just
kind of like you just look stupid yeah
yeah you know stupid because it's yeah
it's just ridiculous like like I feel
like sometimes you just want to give
those people like do you want a day do
you do just like a day to go outside and
yellow your things and get it out of
your system or whatever age yeah the
purge white people purge you go outside
the other n-word like you've got your
one-hour just do your thing come back
inside and let's all be civilized and
you mean like get
out of your system because it doesn't
business it's not gonna change what I'm
doing
it doesn't make you like it doesn't do
anything for you doesn't anything for me
like can we just stop wasting space here
well you know in fairness bill again
it's like what we were talking about
earlier is like you there's something
about there's a tribalism about seeing
people that look like you and feeling
your own I mean I guess I mean that's
the thing too is like there's a segment
of people who are white who feel the
same way you know yeah they feel like I
I liked seeing white people or my mom's
white my dad's white I want to date a
white woman and I mean I just feel like
I think sometimes preference construed
there's something about this how
everyone is now mixing in the world
where like you like you said my mom's
white my dad's white so I'm white my
friends are white public law so
everything I see is white so I get like
there's a part of me that's like like
tribally I get that you're like white
people are great all the white people I
know we're wonderful they're my friends
they're my family they love me they look
after me but for me for you like I'm
like I got a white mom I got a black dad
I got a you know a Korean friend I got a
like so it's like for me it's this other
tour like mosaic of things where I'm
like this is my tribe I'm not looking at
color like you next you're looking at
like personality or whatever ever my dad
used to talk about this how he's like
you know it's very interesting to me how
in America and like North America people
describe people by their hair color
their eye color their skin color he's
like I don't even notice that because
growing up everybody had black hair
black skin and black eyes like so you
had to look at like the nose features
the mouth feature how they found other
ways to be prejudiced right but it's
like that's the thing is like if you are
surrounded by people that were there's
differences then it's like those things
aren't the things that separate you
anymore it's like you find your tribe
being like I like people who like soccer
I like people who like this whatever and
you maybe it is we're finding different
ways to sort of compartmentalize but I
don't know I think that in an enough
fairness once you get if there's a world
where every system ever goes away then
it's gonna be like but everybody who's
under five to a real crazy you know I
mean they're just totally real like when
the aliens attack all of a sudden we're
gonna all be human right right
so it's like I told I totally agree with
you I mean it's just I just want we just
want some open-mindedness I mean yeah so
even even I say to people if you're
white you're watching this and you're
just like yeah you know I have a lot of
white friends it doesn't mean I'm racist
and I agree it doesn't mean you're
racist but it's also but are you
welcoming to people like that's all you
want it to be it's like I don't I don't
mind if you have a tribe but just like
you know make your tribe open you know
that's why there's though like I would
like to know why do you only have white
friends is it because you live in some
isolated place where there's only white
people in which case fine
you know I mean fair enough that's all
the opportunity you had but that's not
really how anyone lives anymore and we
might sing like oh well it's like why
are there only white people on the
screen well there's just lots of white
actors to choose from a lot slit you
don't need this kind of thing but it's
like well is it because like the system
is made to like shift your focus to only
this thing and then you pick from this
thing like let's open it up like you're
saying and like think about why the why
and by the way you know it's funny you
said it we transition but it's a
Hollywood you know it's not this greater
thing but like I had this guy on my
podcast I just released it today his
name is Clive stand and he's on this
show Council of dads on NBC and when I
it's really great show it's so dramatic
but in a good way like my girl watches
and she freaking cries you know but like
anyway the thing that I first interested
me when I was watching this show that
made me kind of go oh brother because it
was like Oh a transgender kid a black
gay doctor you know adopted
light-skinned kid it was like I was like
oh you're trying to fill all the things
right but then I started to I stopped
myself and said oh I only think that way
because everything's white right you
know what I mean and then when you see
something that's not you start to go oh
what are you guys doing are you doing
unquote you know it's like no they're
not feeling like we just got to get more
used to it that's all it is like with
anything
and I mean like with anything so it's
just like you know when you see it it
normalizes it when you're around it it
normalizes it it's like yeah but once
you get into this because like once you
get into the story of it you go all you
forget about all those like because I
I hate the fact that I feel a checkbox
in my head I hate that when I watch a
show and I go it's like you like
especially for a long time you see a
black woman you like okay well they got
that figured out right
that used to be the thing it would be
like let's have a black woman that
covers like female black ethnicity boom
boom you know in a wheelchair and you're
like the story this would be good though
like this is part of it is sometimes you
put you put a black woman and it's like
oh let's ask Chandra tell us black
things it's like it doesn't have to be
pointed out that this person's wife
doesn't know if you pointed out that
this person's no wheelchair whatever I
remember when I first watched how do it
get away with murder
[Music]
like Viola Davis who was a dark skinned
black woman and is just like as like the
in all perfect ways as black as can be
she's eleven thirty it's like Oh
delicious right but like she they had
her married to a white guy and they
never mentioned it it was not a part of
anything it did not come up there wasn't
some sort of big racial thing all the
time there was a couple times when it
came out and that was when it would come
out as you as it would in any
relationship I'm married to a white guy
we don't talk about being a black person
and white like that's just not how our
day is you know but every once in a
while that stuff does come out but I
loved it because the storytelling wasn't
about she's a girl but he's a white man
it was just these two people you know
what it was more about cuz I watched
that show today I still watch it oh yeah
it's more about that guy's preference
was black women right it made it
different where it's lame cuz cuz it cuz
when they go to his past relationships
and it's another black woman you go that
guy like black women
the only reference you make too and then
you're done right as opposed to like but
see see again I've talked about this
other times in my podcast too with other
people it's just you know when you're
right because this is what I hate and I
bet you've experienced this too you go
in for a part alright and you're reading
it and you know reading this this is for
somebody white and you wrote it for
somebody white these six
this person's happy even in this seat
this is a white supposed to be my person
right probably we're like oh [ __ ]
we wrote another white show credit I
mean I'm sure that's not always I'm sure
it's not always that's why I say that
it's on the production level that things
need to change
yeah not what things have already been
made right so it's like things have
already been made and now like the
Oscars comes around
let's not penalize what's already been
made and the people that are put to work
in if you really want to change what
goes on it has to be on the production
level it has to be with the writing and
it has to be with what shows get made
and who's getting hired and that's the
level that that's where it needs to be
done so that's what happens to me is
that going for these shows cuz they're
not writing partially oh let's get a
mixed ethnic whatever look we're not
sure what he is they're not writing that
right you know it's like it goes back to
that whole like the system of they're
not writing it because I don't know the
story they don't have the experience
they probably don't have like ten
friends that look like you they haven't
you know and and so if if the Vey is
like who's traditionally been writing
these things as white dudes in Hollywood
either they need to not need to you but
either it would be beneficial if they
knew people knew those stories or hired
those people and had them tell the
stories and it wasn't just always
through this one lens you don't mean
because it's like that's the I've had
lots of people write stories that are
supposed to be for like a mixed black
woman and they're like perfect you're a
mixed black woman come and say these
words and you're reading it going oh
yeah this doesn't this is the resonate
with me this is not at all but I really
I won't back onto that thing someone
something being written there was a I
was on in Canada and mm-hmm
I was a new hire on it and became part
of the cast and I heard after the fact
that one of the sketches that I was in
they like rewrote just the name of the
person to be Chandra instead of Sharon
they were like oh we gonna make a black
for her Chandra you know and I was like
this is the best so go I totally get
that - aye-aye-aye
if I see a of the name yeah I go are
they gonna change this the guy was on
this show I'm dying up here you know and
you know it was one of these things that
I I think that the original idea for the
character
was supposed to be like Viola Davis
black okay you know this is what the had
in mind yeah but what I did the guy was
like oh that's let's let's have him do
it yeah but then but then when it was
time to make the show it was like were
there people that look like me from
different races and ethnicities at that
time in the 70s and it is are they were
they ready for this so they definitely
augmented the black side of my look like
they made you darker know I had this
afro okay they were like we want to let
you know he's a black man yeah yeah cuz
that's like you know that's the whole
when they did the Nina Simone story and
they gave what's-her-name who played oh
my god anyway they gave her they made
her nose thicker what is her name but
she's a mix like same sort of like not
mixed she's like Central American or
something like that and they like made
her blacker and they were like why
didn't you just hire like Viola Davis
like was one people they said like a
black woman who has a thick nose and
stuff but I'm not like how did you feel
about being made or black yeah I did at
the time I was just when it was I didn't
you know I wasn't thinking about it
until like I thought about it like I
knew what was happening so at the time I
was just like oh you want me to wear
this wig and I was like okay I say I
guess they I thought to myself I guess
they want to they want to make sure
people know this person's black right
and then like just in the first season
the wigs were cheap like can I just put
this out there please hire people who do
black people's hair and makeup and
that's what they did by the way season
two they did hire this my girl Carla
they hire and she and I knew her from
workaholics she was like the hair person
twerk but she she knew too it was like a
certain way need to be done so I went to
this really expensive wig person and the
wig that I have for second season looked
more like this could be my hair right
right yes so it's supposed to like so I
don't but I know what you're saying like
I'm thinking about it in retrospect now
like how should I have felt about are
how do I feel about it now I mean it's
weird you know what I mean it's like are
you
am i appropriating a part of the culture
that I wasn't really a part of right or
am I just playing a part is it same way
that the Joker puts on makeup right you
know I mean there's nobody that has
green making green hair and makeup but
you put you're playing a character as a
character yeah like acting is always
playing somebody who you're not exactly
you like it was I was thinking it was
always held honor and you know I mean
and and so but like the philosophical
question is if I'm gonna act as anybody
else then why can't I act as more black
or whatever but then why can't a white
person act is black or why can't a
person who's sis act as trends and like
where is the line or how does that work
and part of it is like you know in the
end of my like am I am I are they
forcing me into this role like when they
made Charlize Theron be ever all that
makeup for the role of monster it's like
just find a woman who's not the most
beautiful one in the world and let her
act the role there's tons of women who
look more like that actual prison but
like am I taking a role away from
somebody but we're not Lena but also
this is my craft and I want to be doing
this and like I'm getting a job and I
want to take the job and like it's not
my response to you was not government
assigned right like they're not they're
not government-affiliated this is this
is a private business who has the right
to you know listen famous people are
this isn't for like let's make everybody
get a role because they should get a
role like I was totally against it
whatever what's the lady that played she
was the Black Widow and Avengers and she
was gonna be a transgender actress and
she got a lot of flack for it and they
were like oh so they they cancelled the
role or whatever
no one saw mana for the guy you need to
look it up on the internet but what why
am I forgetting her name she's like so
famous of course you wouldn't know
anything about the about the Avengers
I'm the word Sun even I don't know about
the Avengers I am the worst at knowing
remembering like celebrities names any
enemy no I'm so terrible at it Scarlett
Johansson okay Scarlett Johansson Susan
so what I'm saying is like Scarlett
Johansson is super famous we're putting
her in the movie because that's gonna
make people come see it
you know like it's not our job to make
sure that you know some unknown
transgender actress gets this part like
it's like but then also looks like that
slippery scale of like never get to be
no I dreamt under doctor ever get to be
known because they're always taking you
know you mean like nobody gets to play
like that does that transgendered actor
have to like what do they have to do to
get in in the room for that part cuz
maybe they're phenomenal and then then
it would be great you know I want to
struggle that other people who are
transgender have that this character has
that someone else would have to learn or
may never really I would I would like to
believe that if someone is that
brilliant they're gonna get a role I
hope so
you know that's how I feel about it I
would like to think that that's how this
because I feel that way to get a back
full circle to what we were originally
talking about is a comedy and that's how
I feel about comedy I feel like if
you're funny you're gonna shine through
you're gonna some you're gonna get an
opportunity are there more opportunities
for people who are less talented who are
white probably but it's like such an
equal it's a much more equal playing
field because like you don't have to be
pretty you don't have to be unit I mean
like you can in white here you know you
can do comedy row like for I'm thinking
of like as a woman you know generally in
Hollywood it's like they want a city
pretty they want us to look young like
for comedy i recipe pretty i don't have
to look young I can just if I have
something that's funny to say people
will laugh you know and like you can go
and do an open mic especially in this
city there's like so many opportunities
and yeah now with our phones and all
this stuff we can create our own things
but it's just not the same it's like you
know a Hollywood movie like that's like
a strike of lightning and then when it
does strike like only a few people are
gonna get that opportunity so it's not
just doesn't feel like the I feel like
comedies a lot more equal in a lot of
ways than TV and films it's interesting
that you feel that way because I don't
necessarily look at it like that I think
that I think there's very much a
disproportionate amount of people in the
comedy world that is very much it's a
very much about how you look and kind of
I think that it's very much like a
benefit I mean this is an image business
to I mean you know it's like if you were
funny and not good-looking who do well
the ones that are very good-looking and
are even if like let's say you had a
scale of like good-looking here and
comedy talent here and I think that this
person is gonna do far more than this
person do you think it's the same for
like everybody like men women black no I
think it's very different that's what
I'm saying it's not equal like I'll say
this I've I feel like that femininity on
stage is scary to people in the crowd
sometimes I think that when a woman is
on stage being a woman and beautiful and
sometimes people in the crowd have a
weird reaction to that like that's why
femininity is hidden so much
it's why you female comics so we wear
ponytails and jeans and and try to look
like a boy on stage to like so you could
just get your point out there without
you know you know to me without you know
yeah I mean like we get I think that
women like even when I post videos vids
I you know the the comments that I get
are often about the way I look are this
kind of stuff and like I wear jeans
because I move around and have deep
squats you mean like I'm like listen I
totally get it but I'm saying you're not
you know it's like when's the last time
you seen a female comic on stage not
wearing a miniskirt but I'm just saying
like looking like like girly girly I
like to when I have like my show boots
and let me tell you boots but like I I
don't like to play down my femininity I
I don't I'm not a super fancy like tits
out kind of person generally so like I
like to play up me and also now that I'm
going out to shows I'm like momma's out
of the house like let's put some makeup
on let's do you know II mean so when I
go and do this if I'm like not trying to
play it down but no matter if I if I do
wear that other stuff like I feel like
people are still commenting anyway so
I'm like might as well wear what I want
to wear and then like say what I want to
say cuz all people are gonna say is
she's fat she's a [ __ ] she says it like
it's like the stuffs not gonna be about
the comedy that's what like even when
the guy was like that's why you're good
slaves I'm like did you like the joke
like I'm like that's what's more
like are you laughing that it you know
that's what--when in a certain way like
he was adding to your joke yeah way you
know it was like he thought it was like
ah you're gonna you know you just go
okay I see you went with my he actually
what he loves the joke because he went
if your logic just appropriated it to
something like but I'm just saying like
in again and getting back to just think
about equality I just I just dyed I
don't know I don't believe that it's
equal because I feel like a man when a
man's onstage his masculinity is used to
enhance his comedy you know like an
alpha male comic you know being an alpha
male onstage being like a man masculine
is very rewarding because you know if
you could just look down the line of the
those type of comments or like the most
successful actions how it's been for a
very long time I don't I don't think the
comment is equal I just think it's like
I don't know maybe because I'm a woman
in come in in comedy and also in you
know the business of like acting and
stuff that that's definitely something
I've heard from managers agents all
those people like you've got to look
better when you go for your auditions
you've got to learn how to do your make
like all these things that like guys
just don't here you know II mean in the
same at the same level in the same way
and like how old am i they wanted to
hide my age all the time because I look
younger than I am and so they were like
we want you to go up to these other
roles don't ever tell anyone your age
and I'm like I'm not good at lying like
I'm like I don't want to be a part of
that stuff whereas for comedy no one's
ever cared about how old I am
you don't need me no one that this
doesn't matter like how you did comedy
the whole time I was pregnant and I went
up on stage with this big belly and it
was great cuz I was just like deal with
me now like it was so much fun just to
be like that is a you cannot deny I am a
woman when I've hung there like eight
months
that's better than your boots and makeup
totally I was like just like yeah no
makeup on hair askew but I'm a bit I'm a
woman you know just it's yeah it's just
different I think I don't know I was
taking some headshots one time and in
the in the the photographer's assistant
was this like like really strong lesbian
woman you know what I mean lesbian
feminists it was just so I was fun
joking around with her so I'm in her car
you know I'm in her
car that was a real interesting
transition because she's driving us to a
different Schaefer location so like in
her car her [ __ ] when he's open glove
boxes you know and and I and it was like
a like a Passat or something like you
would like a stereotypical female car
right and I look and I'm looking in this
thing and I go yeah this is this is a
real female car and she goes oh why
because it's whatever it is Annette I
just go no it's probably this handful of
tampons that are right here you know and
I just loved it because it was like it
was like a moment where she was like
uh-uh too much and your copy of the
feminist mystique everything is not
everything is that you get like I think
that I mean I haven't experienced a ton
of it because I think that I just don't
notice it as much maybe as some other
people you didn't don't notice repeating
blacks I grew up in a place where that
wasn't as big of a thing I don't notice
keep being a woman as much because I
grew up in the family that was much more
equal but when I when someone does say
something that comes out of a blue and
scenes comes out of the blue and seems
like off I'm like my brain instantly
goes to is it because I'm a woman is it
because I'm black is it because of these
like you know we have that where
somebody else who's white and a man
doesn't he just be like oh this person's
an [ __ ] whereas I'm like yeah point
now I'm getting to the point now for me
to I feel I feel like it's like you know
it's like I I mean my Quarantine beard
right now you know I know I almost
didn't recognize you when you came
another cool snap okay you know what the
funny thing about it is is like so like
I usually just have a mustache and like
I just did this movie and then they
would let the Creator she was like wow I
really want your mustache to be dark and
your hair to be dark you know so I died
you know you know and sometimes I'll die
anyway just because I like how it looks
right but like now I've done this and
it's like now it's like okay is this me
now am I like am i this old guy
now can I go back like what like what
you know I mean like you know this is a
really question can you go back cuz now
that this is happening and just by the
way I think it looks good okay I
appreciate it saying that him even my
girl likes it but we had a little like
thing about it the other day when she
was like I think you should dye your
hair and I was like I was like yeah but
this is me now like I'm trying to accept
that this is me and you know if you go
in now and you diet it's gonna look so
like if so if everyone's been seeing you
like this
it's gonna be such a shock to the system
no I don't know so we got into this
whole thing about it cuz I even asked
her why do you want me to die but anyway
it just becomes this thing that you're
what you talk about so for me it's like
now I have a whole other host of things
I have to worry about yeah you know so
I'm going in this like all baby dude am
I too fat for this am I too old looking
for this am I too ethnic for this one's
got their things
everybody's got their things that
they're like always thinking about when
somebody says something so it's like I
guess we just have to have a moment of
like let me just pause let me not think
the worst right that's that's a great
point though like you know thinking the
best and I think before I used to always
assume the best in every situation I was
like ridiculously positive and
optimistic you didn't mean and and then
not just like oh I've become Grizzles
because I haven't I'm still positive and
optimistic about a lot of stuff but I
think moving to America and hearing like
people say stuff and and hearing things
and how things go and these jokes and
something sometimes I am like oh wow
yeah there really is there's something
else that I have never experienced that
I
and now anticipating people saying or
feeling that I feel like I should be
seeing like one of my friends is like I
hate white people and I was like I could
never say that you don't need me like
I'm like I could never say hey white
people because I don't but also because
my mom's white and like oh I'm not gonna
hate my mom like and he's like yeah but
you have to understand like I've been I
felt the oppression I felt the racism I
felt that stuff and I'm like cool yeah
but like doesn't that then cut off the
ability for us to get along which is the
thing we want like and when
someone says something like that they
just go I hate wipe it and then I it's
just my brain just goes like so you hate
all white so like you know I mean it's
like and I I have a proxy I'm a tweener
in terms of like when I was a kid like
the idea of racism was heavy
yeah and then I've grown up into this in
a world where it's like it's different
you know
so it's so but I still have people who
think all white people are - man that's
that you know - right I don't like that
like us versus them thing yeah all the
stuff like I don't like I rant a lot
about like the different you know being
a woman or being black hats after having
said I don't like the talk but in the
end it's like yeah I don't I don't want
to separate us all all the time because
I just feel like that's that's boring
you know I don't want to only talk to
people who have my same experience
that's roaring I can connect with them
on that but like that's not all I want
that's why I like that's why people like
to travel and see different things and
try different foods and stuff you don't
even it's different I just think the
sentence just needs to be unpacked as
all it is you know when somebody says I
hate white people I just think you just
hate the idea of what it was before and
like you just don't you I need to
remember so that never happens again I
mean sighs have that like mentality and
I just gotta like you know it's like not
you don't hate all white people not
really white people are the man yeah the
way it's like it's bother I feel it's
more economical now than it is racial
cuz my thing is like if you're on the
bus on the way to work and you're
sitting next to a white guy guess what
he's not the man if you live in an
apartment building and you in in your
next-door neighbor's why y'all living in
the same place like yeah that is you too
man I mean it's like so I'm just saying
like when people are like that
and he goes both ways these people like
this guy that wants to people they had
like people that hate anyone and it's
like why yeah but what has happened in
your life right now to make you feel
this way like the indoctrination that
people
still have from their families that
carries down I mean it takes generations
for these things to go away if you think
about it I always look at sports as an
example of that you know like Jackie
Robinson the the anniversary of Jackie
Robinson joining the the baseball league
there's people still alive right hated
black people a yeah I got a newsletter
to know we like black okay so my mom's
mom you know she was a white lady from
rural Manitoba in Canada like she was
you know she's she's that that person
who had never met black people who had
never done so so when she she was very
upset that my mom married a black man my
dad's family was all real upset that he
married a white woman they're like white
devil they take all of our people away
they never come back like you know and
then it was like it took that like
interracial love coming together and
then a baby my brother was a firstborn
grandchild on both sides and it was like
this kid who was a mix and you just made
a kid like I don't care if you hate what
you hate in your life but you just can't
and my grandmother you know the story
goes that my grandmother was like real
upset and then they they showed her the
first grandbaby and she was like you
know this is this is the most beautiful
little n-word I've ever seen and it's
like this my brother has a podcast about
that kind of stuff where you're like she
was trying so hard to reach out and show
love and to hurt that note that word is
normal that's what you called black
people like that doesn't see bad you
don't mean so it's like finding that
balance of like well how do we I'm not
gonna be like well screw you grandma for
having lived in a time where this was
just what happened that's not your fault
but then now yeah like you got to get
the newsletter at some point and not be
walking around yelling that works people
especially when you're walking with your
little Negro child like as she would
call him as her nice version of the end
where you don't think it's like that
kind of thing so there's still lot like
there's still love in there even through
all the hate and racism there's still
love I just think it's like people say
things and they just need to unpack it
yeah totally I need to unpack my why
they yeah why mm-hmm it's the same thing
I get to get it back to comedy it's like
you know I
would say please don't assume ill intent
of this joke that I just said to you for
you to assume ill intent means that you
know you don't understand the process of
what comedy is even about yeah maybe if
you know if you just go oh I didn't
appreciate that or I thought that was
little off-color or I thought that was
inappropriate is one thing but to assume
like oh you said this thing so that
means you are you hate women you hate me
you hate this you wait it's like no it's
just maybe it's a joke that didn't hit
with you right yeah yeah we've been
talking for like an hour so ideally
gonna like it I want to hear more about
your you can about your album and where
it is and how people can see it and will
help people to hear it and watch it so
the album just came out on Friday a very
exciting it's called all the parts and
it's like basically the story of me you
and I mean like I talked about my whole
life and going from being a single woman
to now being a married woman with a
child it's a lot of fun super proud of
it all things comedy produced it and
then 800-pound gorilla Records released
it on their label so it's on iTunes
Pandora Spotify all the places you can
get albums on there and the video the
video this special will be coming out in
July will be coming out in July I just
spoke with ATC guys just to go turn
their nail down what day it's gonna come
out the end of Monday and July but I'll
uh I'll be posting about it so so yeah
there'll be some time to get the jokes
in the head audio and then you can see
how they got acted out on stage well
that's great
yeah really this and I appreciate all
that you're doing I like your
perspective I think you know I feel like
I feel like we doing that thing like
we're seeing each other and I realized
there is a shared experience of being
like a mixed-race yeah I'm like you know
like because well if it's hard to hate
anybody when you're mixed-race right
yeah you start to hate people for their
intentions you start hate to people for
their actions for their leaders not for
that person yeah yeah cuz it's just a
nature of this because I don't I always
say my long-standing joke is like I
wouldn't I'm fine with not knowing like
not be
whenever except for if I was in jail
because I wouldn't know where gang to
join right it's just you and one other
mix guy like for me is like whoever's
winning great sketch I want to see you
make that sketch I should you right so
you just with whoever's winning in here
Muslim yeah you know and like this for
me it's like I pride myself on being
like you know I've been on like I've
been on like BT mhm
you know I've been on you know Comedy
Central
you know I've been on different like I
was on a my first ever TV appearance was
the payaso comedy slam and it was like a
Latino based so I'm like I'm always your
other things
yeah I'm you're every woman that Chaka
Khan was talking about just in this but
it is but listen I wish you all the best
I wish you much success and I look
forward to like watching your video and
and then I have Spotify Samba check out
I'm gonna check out your album give a
review but anyway this has been the
lovely and talented very competitive new
mom recently mom
how long you been married to a less than
two years yeah we got married in October
it'll be off in two years in October
she goes quick so I have a whole
football team by the time I know her
name is spelled with an A but it's
Aishah there you go
thank you Alfa and uh listen thanks for
being on the show you know what I love
about this platform is like you know
when when would we ever decide to like
sit down and just have an hour long talk
about all these different topics and
really be engaged like this so it's like
it's amazing how this platform allows
for even and the people watching to be
like oh I would they like that or to
chime in because they're gonna chime in
all of you mixed colored you know we're
gonna say you know I get some
interesting debates and in the chat in
the comments sometimes but let's talk
about all the things like what's the new
phase
exactly exactly but but anyways once
again everybody say goodbye to the very
lovely and make sure you check out all
of her stuff it's on the iTunes Spotify
almost audio platforms what's the name
of the album again all the parts all the
parts and all the information is gonna
be down below you can find her website
and all that kind of stuff I'll have all
the information right there but it wants
to go give it up for the very talented
miss Aisha thank you very much for being
thanks for having me really nice
[Music]
[Applause]